let's start off with bob saget comedian
full house star dead at 65 years old at
orlando uh ritz carlton a hotel i've
stayed at many times i grew up watching
this guy with full house i don't know
about you guys but we grew up maybe
maybe even my english got better by
watching full house and bob saget when
that story came out it was uh
it was absolutely bizarre because wasn't
he just on uh uh he was on a podcast he
was on rogan podcast or something i
think a year ago even joe posted it on
his instagram about bob saget the
libquely's podcast also believe it or
not one of the better rappers
and bob saget and we were just uh me and
caroline middle javik were just at the
orlando improv stayed at that hotel like
three days before they're saying that
there was no funny business they found
no drug he was a healthy 65 year old guy
i don't know what he had going on you're
not gonna you're not gonna get me down
this you're not gonna get me down as
well you love conspiracy theories so go
somewhere what are you talking about is
taking off the air what are you talking
about
i'd love to know what type of
medicine
he took
right
but but that is the story that's going
around okay so so there is there are
people that are speculating wizard
because anytime something like this
happen at 65 you know what was it was
there something else he had just
performed that night right crazy i will
say this though when i was younger 65
was like well he was 65. now i'm like 65
seems so young exactly like if anybody
dies under 80 it's like to me
that's why social security started at
62. because you only are expected to
make it to 65 and it wasn't it wasn't
supposed to be a a lifelong payout plan
because you were supposed to be just
basically like all right yeah enjoy your
rocking chair for three years boom
you're dead now people are living in
85.95 no problem isn't that one of the
weird things though we look we think
about like society like is crumbling
around us at all times and it's like man
yeah it got died at 65 and it's like man
we've we're doing pretty good here as a
people right like within a 30-year span
we've you know 33 percent of our
lifespan our life expectancy and
everybody's like the sky's falling all
the time look
i don't want to you know enter any
conspiracy what do you think actually
happened with bob saget here i think you
have to wait and see because you know
there's always they said that they said
that the autopsy is going to be did you
weeks and weeks and weeks you want to
hear you just asked me you just want to
go ahead biz doc
you're 65 tell us what it's like when it
is oh i got your 65 right here
with this thing right here um
no i you know about um about was it six
seven months ago there was a very
prominent african american actor that
passed away in new york and
and then for a whole week it was very
very sad and there was speculation then
it turns out in the autopsy he had a
relapse he started using again and he
had
cardiopulmonary paralysis basically
caused himself a heart attack it was
very very tragic a lot of his friends
said you know we thought he had gotten
through this and everything but
apparently remember that who was the
actor i don't remember the name you talk
about bam you're talking about chadwick
boseman they're not here
that was cancer that yeah that was
cancer this is something else and so
right now what you've got i'm talking
about the guy from the wire
omar
michael
seemingly nice guy in all his interviews
very very gifted character actor very
very very fun to watch
um and there was this calm right and
then we found out and i just hope you
know that this isn't one of those things
i don't hope that saggett had a heart
attack but i hope it's like natural
causes or something and
yeah i would really be bummed out if
it's yet another positive one using i
want to know what he knew about you know
what information he knew that would lead
to the arrest of hillary clinton i mean
that's really
that's where you're going with this
unbelievable pat you came to the united
states 1992 1990 november 1990. i think
i saw sagging this t-shirt oswald acted
alone that's right this was the height
of full house early 90. you must have
watched full house saved by the bells
these types of shows yep
they you probably literally learned
english watching tanner family he's
probably one of my english teachers
he gave you the 1.8 gpa congratulations
so tell us
what comes to mind when you think of bob
sage look i don't i don't know the man
so i can't give my opinions on it but i
just when i when i study somebody in an
interview and you hear how how they're
talking and who they are the stories you
know he was a guy that you know
liked women partied all this stuff like
you hear a lot of stories about him
being a party guy but he had settled on
he was in a more of a serious
relationship but this is a guy that to
us you watch this guy on tv so when you
see something like this taking place
it's tragic i'm sure the family is
furious right now devastated right now
they're going through tough times uh
just wanted to give our condolences to
the sagitt family and obviously the
stories whatever's going to come out
we'll wait for it but let me let me ask
g
he's a comedian yeah you're a comedian i
did comedy for a long time as a comedian
how do you process this uh you know
what's weird the um does he perform that
night yeah i know you know uh
the one that hit me hardest was when uh
greg geraldo that's my favorite yeah
when when greg geraldo died in jersey at
the stress factory the club where i was
starting full on drugs yeah well he
always was but like you know he was so
good for so long like nobody really knew
about geraldo
great pull him up you'll know him like
the roast master general but you know
the thing with bob saget man is that he
lives on forever like the weird thing
that we're all doing in this industry is
we're chasing immortality why do we not
go after money why we everything's
legacy you know he's going to live on
forever in reruns he's going to live up
one of the things i don't like is how
the internet and the internet's the
internet it is what it is you know
people are calling them a pedo they're
calling them all these other things
because of some of the raunchy jokes
that he made and you know he's he's a
very very very blue comic for people
that don't he was not danny tanner no no
no
that was an act he was not danny he was
also on america's funniest home videos
yeah yeah but he was really the guy who
did the aristocrats jokes and that was
what he was living on his that's the
living room persona but his comedy was
way out
and uh you know but he lives on i mean
basically bojack horseman is an entire
series based on him i mean satirizing
him you know and and i mean you know
really what it comes down to is like
look at how culturally relevant that pop
comedy was like uh lannis morissette
jagged little pill one of the greatest
selling albums of all time do you know
who
the breakup was that caused all those
yeah it was danny uh it was cool yeah
exactly cut it out the corniest the guy
on tv yeah that's responsible for
atlanta where she's crying and remember
about that
so i mean bob saget look also guys i
mean betty white bob saget here's the
other side of it that everybody's
listening to this like we're getting
older yeah
this is this is kind of like brendan
shaw when we had him on it was a cold
comment that he had but it was the right
comment when we were like you know david
cuts in and goes guys betty white died
and all of us are like oh that's
breaking news yeah 99 years old he's
like yeah that's what 99 year olds do
i'm like damn dude
i'll tell you one quick uh bob saget
story and then i'm sure we want to move
on so
i've met some pretty you know known
people especially in my time in la when
i was doing the whole kardashian thing
and i'm sitting at a restaurant like
this and in the booth behind me i'm with
my boys and i turn around
i'm like holy [ __ ] it's bob saget and
he's sitting there
with john mayer the two of them and
they're going over jokes because john
mayer talented musician
it was trying to break through into
comedy i'm sure you've known me you've
been doing that with uh
chappelle exactly
so and i'm thinking [ __ ] bob saget is
coaching up john mayer over here about
stand-up comedy i'm like this is pretty
freaking cool
and i was like hey guys can i no they're
just like that's speeding
that's where it ends okay rest in peace
uh bob saget exactly story was i'm just
saying like
right
we're expecting
sagitta story john mayer you know you
know what patch is no guys i'm out of
here you know
america's got this big fascination with
celebrity deaths america has this huge
fascination tabloid fascination
death in general bro yes discovery id
murder docs i mean you got it you got it
but anyway the point is i remember
way back when you know e.t was covering
and i mean the show not the little guy
uh the death of farah fawcett america's
sweetheart one of the first pinups and
everything farrah fawcett has passed
away today
and what pat just did is what happened
at three o'clock pacific time that day
and fairfall said love by all wait a
minute wait a minute michael jackson has
been rushed to the hospital so everybody
forgets that farrah fawcett died in the
morning michael jackson died in the
afternoon and all the the et stuff they
literally stopped mid-sentence so pat
was just right here all right done
here's the hook so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]